>> Gutfeld: SCOOBY DOO?
MOLEX COULD BE DON'T.
NO, STOP IT.
TAKE THAT, SHAKESPEARE!
A CARTOON CHARACTER CAN'T CALL
AUTHORITIES BECAUSE IT MIGHT
OFFEND CARTOON MINORITIES.
A NEW VIDEO GAME FEATURING VELMA
OF SCOOBY DOO HAS MADE SOME
CHANGES AFTER PEOPLE SUGGESTED
SHE WAS A RACIST KAREN FOR BEING
ABLE TO CALL THE COPS ON BLACK
CHARACTERS.
SHE STILL GETS BONUS POINTS
THOUGH FOR BEING A, THANKFULLY.
A BEAUTIFUL.
MULTI-VERSES IS FIGHTING GAME
INVOLVING LeBRON GAMES DOMINIC
JAMES FROM "SPACE JAM" TO, DEPOT
THOUGHT IT WAS MESSED UP THAT
VELMA COULD CALL POLICE.
HERE'S A CLIP OF HER TAKING DOWN
LeBRON.
♪ ♪
>> YOU'RE IN BIG TROUBLE, NOW.
>> VICTORY!
B3 BOY MY WORLD.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED.
THAT WAS LeBRON FLOPPING
AROUND ON THE GROUND TRYING TO
DRAW A FOUL.
I KNOW MY SPORTS.
I WROTE THAT JOKE MYSELF BECAUSE
I KNOW SPORTS.
AS WE COULD HAVE PREDICTED, FEW
PEOPLE ACTUALLY COMPLAINED ABOUT
THIS GAME.
IT WAS A PETITION BUT ONLY A
COUPLE OF DOZEN PEOPLE SIGNED
IT.
BUT THAT'S ALL IT TAKES TO SCARE
THESE CASTRATED COMPANIES.
APPARENTLY THIS WILL REMOVE THE
BAD VIBES THAT PEOPLE OF COLOR
GET WHEN THEY SEE A COP CAR.
IT REPLACES THE FEAR WITH THE
FEAR OF GETTING INTO A VAN WITH
FOUR WEIRDOS AND A TALKING DOG.
I DON'T THINK WE COULD'VE ENDED
ON A QUIETER NOTE WITHOUT JOKE.
I SHOULD HAVE ANNOUNCED THAT
KENNETH STARR PASSED AWAY AND
NOBODY WOULD LAUGH.
HAVE YOU BEEN UPSET BY
SCOOBY DOO?
>> HAVE I BEEN UPSET BY
I LOVE SCOOBY DOO.
I DID A MOVIE WITH SCOOBY DOO.
>> I HAVE A CLIP.
ROLL IT.
♪ ♪
>> TIME TO CALL YO MAMA!
>> Gutfeld: OH, MAN!
[APPLAUSE]
>> Gutfeld: HELEN DID YOU
TRAIN FOR THAT PART?
>> I DID MY OWN STUNTS FOR THAT
ONE.
SHOUT OUT TO AAA.
AS A BLACK MAN I COULD NOT BE
MORE ANNOYED BY THE STUPID
STORY.
WHO PICKS HER IN A FIGHT GAME?
FIRST OF ALL.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
ANYTHING.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS.
IT WAS ONE GUY, HE SAID THE
MAGIC WORD.
HE SAID THAT AS A BLACK MAN HE'S
OFFENDED SEEING SOMEONE
ARRESTED.
SHE SOLVES THE MYSTERY THAT YOU
DID SOMETHING WRONG, MAKES A
WANTED SIGN, THEN SHE CALLS THE
POLICE.
BACK IN THE DAY, THAT WOULD BE A
RESPONSIBLE YOUNG ADULT.
YOU SEE SOMETHING BAD HAPPEN,
YOU CALL THE POLICE AND THEY
COME AND INVESTIGATE.
NO WHAT THEY WANT TO HAPPEN IS
THAT IF YOU SEE SOMETHING YOU
DON'T LIKE, YOU THEY CALL THEM
MOB, THEY KIDNAP THEM AND PUT
THEM IN A VAN AND TAKE THEM
AWAY.
THESE WOKE COWARDS ONCE AGAIN
ARE ATTACKING THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
IT'S PATHETIC.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Gutfeld: THIS IS ALMOST
LIKE A PARALLEL TO THE LAST
BLOCK IN THAT WE HAVE LOWERED
THE BAR OF WHAT'S OFFENSIVE.
IT'S GOT TO OFFEND YOU BECAUSE
YOU ARE OFFENSIVE.
>> I'D RATHER HEAR VELMA SAY,
LET'S GO BRANDON RATHER THAN ALI
AKBAR.
YOU BROUGHT IT ON YOURSELVES.
IF THEY REALLY WANT TO MAKE
VELMA CONTEMPORARY SHE SHOULD
MEET TO SCOOBY FOR PUTTING HIS
NOSE AND HER WITHOUT CONSENT.
FOR YEARS!
>> Gutfeld: YOU KNOW CAT,
EVERY EPISODE THE VILLAIN WAS
ALWAYS A RICH OLD WHITE GUY.
LIKE OLD MEN McGILLICUDDY.
REVERSE RACISM.
>> I AM TOO YOUNG.
>> Gutfeld: THAT'S ALL SHE
HEARD.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
PEOPLE WHO SIT AROUND PLAYING
VIDEO GAMES I USED TO CALL THEM
LOSERS UNTIL I GOT ADDICTED FOR
A YEAR.
I STOPPED WHEN I GOT TO A
FIVE-STAR ISLAND.
THANKS FOR THE CONGRATULATIONS.
IT'S NOT THAT EASY.
MOST PEOPLE ONLY MAKE IT TO
FOUR-STAR MACS AT ANIMAL
CROSSING PEOPLE.
EVEN IF YOUR HOBBY IS DRINKING,
THAT'S A BETTER HOBBY.
>> Gutfeld: BUT THE REWARDS
DIMINISH.
IT'S EVEN WORSE WHEN YOU QUIT.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS GOING TO
SOLVE A LOT OF MAJOR PROBLEMS?
WHEN YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT THE
FEELINGS OF A FICTIONAL
CHARACTER?
IN FICTION WORLD, EVERYBODY'S
HAPPY NOW, EVERYBODY WORKS.
>> THE MORE IT REFLECTS ON YOUR
REAL LIFE.
IT'S A VICTIMHOOD CULTURE ON
STEROIDS.
WE HAVE TO LOOK TO A VIDEO GAME
FOR VICTIMS BECAUSE THERE AREN'T
ANY LEFT IN REAL LIFE.
IT DOES SEEM A LITTLE BIT RACIST
AS A PRESUPPOSITION THAT YOU CAN
CALL THE POLICE ON ANYBODY BUT
WHAT WERE WORRIED ABOUT HER THAT
SHE IS GOING TO CALL THE POLICE
ON A BLACK MAN.
FOR AS I CAN TELL, ANY OF THESE
GUYS COULD HAVE THE POLICE
CALLED THEM.
VIDEO GAMES THERE ARE VICTIMHOOD
GOGGLES IT WILL AS WELL.
NOT LIKE I WROTE A BOOK ABOUT
ANYTHING.
>> I'M WORRIED ABOUT THE FACT
THAT SHAGGY LOOKS LIKE HE MAKES
METH IN A BA